alla fine vi devo dovremo mettere un
cartello scritto ci siamo resi conto che
questi erano fallimentari scusateci fine
[Musica]
no ancora no cosa fa allora a stanno a
lavorare capito stanno ora che chi di
barbie kimberly in carriera ma che cosa
sarebbe meglio che cosa non quadra piano
fa attenzione ragazzi devo dirvi che è
che gigi d'alessio ucciso con un uomo ct
voglio dire
me lo spiegate vi devo fare il provino
attenzione ma da dove che ve ne frega no
state lavorando a un centro slavi
entrate che forse ai più noto antonio
maniglio insultato e cerco hanno
riaperto le storie mario martone domani
[Applauso]
sorriso solito tutto bello in culture
polmone come faccia bene staderini
[Applauso]
ora che si cerca siamo impazziti
devo intervenire
cosa succede ben evidenti gli stati samb
rischio ming ha trovato il rote trovato
allora è una proposta dicono che
sembrano stare a 5 metri l'uno
dall'altro le persone a due metri di
distanza tra le persone dove distanza
riesco a vederti costume senza occhiali
devo niente fortunato non veder che
comunque poi i sensi di entrata uscita
per il mare
tu pensa io nelle porte in capisco manco
e tirare spingere è manco io andiamo
bene ma toccava la villa per far bagno
fino a lega non lo so la fila pure per
fare il bagno ma che kakà dinho
comunque un certo punto avevano proposto
anche il plexiglass mi avete tipo nero
scuro chiti scherma danno ancora un
black sea glass tipo labirinto degli
specchi dove viene deformato già prende
la gente sia sicuro i fa cagare per con
lei forniti di un bravo ma il bagno tra
congiunti la vasca la chiamo la montagna
ma che ci fa tipo pronto
scusi chi le propone dopo parla poco
dopo sempre su nutrizionista scusi chi
le ha dato i miei
maniera oddio il nutrizionista
tocca a salirci se come io ho perso
qualcosa non è di più punto no se faccio
ora così aspetta e fai ma prova a
pensarti un polo il collo no no presente
che in più secondo me è rotta cioè senso
se facciamo si guarda tra l'altro peso
le scelte poltiche le galline tutt'uno
col penna senso non ci credo
farina ti chiama conferma che non è
rotta si lancia fini dice ad essere
usate tanzi chisso numero che definisca
che per le banche welfare discorso che
iscriversi basta piace licenza sticazzi
batte nutrizionista però mi sta andando
estiqaatsi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sono perciò a fine video dovremo mettere
un cartello detto ci siamo resi conto
che costruite erano fallimentari
scusateci fine dovremmo chiedere di
commettere scrive investigati prezzi
abbiamo sbagliato tutto e stato un
fallimento
la linea pesa su una realtà lavinia
scusa che ci fai la sopra è stata
protetta 4 in più secondo vedere solido
[Risate]
come tra parentesi non è questo il mio
paese che non ne rivelo
[Risate]
gianni mai pur trovare ps6 e gianni rosa
di cuceglio costa coda ma chi
[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
bravissimi
[Musica]
[Applauso]